how do you start a scene in an
interesting way you can reach for a wide
shot that establishes the location but
that's often overused and sometimes the
location is not actually that important
to the scene you could just open on a
character in the middle of some dialogue
you could choose a shot that corresponds
with the end of the previous scene to
create a smooth transition you could
open on something that creates a
question that will be answered later
intriguing the audience you could open a
scene on a visual call back to the first
shot of the season yes tell Howard
you're not quitting retiring or whatever
or with an action that you'll repeat at
the end of the scene allowing you to
show contrast and giving the scene nice
structural bookends you could build a
motif of opening shots that helps the
audience understand what's important to
the character in this case her work the
audience will subconsciously place
emphasis on the subject of the first
shot of the scene you can use this
emphasis to your advantage
better call Saul opens scenes in a
variety of creative ways but they employ
one technique that I think creatively
uses the full potential of an
establishing shot sometimes they'll open
a scene on a subject that is a symbol of
the scenes conflict here's an example
you're kidding right
you realize how far behind I am not to
mention now I've got eight entire wills
to finish up what are you talking about
I'll do the Wills of course it will do
the Wills they're my clients they're my
clients the conflict of this scene
centers around Kim taking on some of
Jimmy's clients so how do you start the
scene with a shot of one of those
clients
this seems underlying conflict is Jimmy
trying to butter up to a prosecuting
attorney with food to gain some
information so was it how was what the
scenes conflict rests on the fact that
the attorneys normal lunch is
undesirable making Jimmy's casual bribe
desirable so how do you start this scene
with a shot of the attorneys weak coffee
being poured in the machine the shot
also by the way acts as a callback to
the first season where shots of coffee
being poured in this machine were used
repeatedly so it also establishes the
location mine is a cartel business but
it is mine and it is legitimate in this
scene the conflict created for Gus by
Hector Salamanca's presence in his
business is symbolized by the locked
door Hector is intimidating Gus by
taking control of the restaurant and
that control is perfectly summed up by
the image of one of Hector's thugs
unlocking the door for Gus
whatever we do in this scene the
conflict created by Jimmy having to
stall for time until someone arrives is
symbolized by the clock actually would
you mind if I messenger that over
tomorrow morning first thing I'd like to
take one last look before we submit just
double-check a few things
sure so tomorrow first thing this scenes
conflict centers around Kim's
perfectionism the actual cause of the
conflict Kim's work is used here not a
symbol Chuck was right about you all
alone he's mentally ill what is your
excuse
enjoy your champagne in this scene the
champagne in the opening shot is a
symbol of the scenes conflict about how
to appropriately respond to the bar
hearings outcome you see in this scene
the lamps given prominence in the center
of the opening shot are a symbol of the
conflict in the scene over Chuck's
condition and are themselves one of the
causes of conflict for Chuck sometimes
the conflict symbolized is one that's
deeper or more subtextual this opening
shot of the log chuck has made of his
symptoms emphasizes the disconnect
between his rational evidence-based
approach to life and his psychosomatic
illness which is the internal conflict
that led to him reaching out to his
therapist for this meeting
this shot symbolizes both the legal
conflict created by the state border
that Kim is trying to help resolve in
the scene and the conflict created by
the depth of the sand when her car gets
stuck in it later a conflict which
itself is symbolic of the broader
conflict of her overworking herself
there are many other examples throughout
every season of better call Saul of this
kind of technique you didn't
drain your bank account did you in order
to use this technique you have to have a
writer that writes scenes that have a
clear subtextual or textual conflict and
you have to have a cinematographer who
can get an interesting shot that
symbolizes that conflict and an editor
who doesn't always reach for the most
obvious wide shot when establishing a
scene and of course these types of
opening shots can be combined with
others you can have a transition to an
opening shot of the symbol of conflict
you can have an establishing shot that
generates mystery and also shows the
object of conflict in a show where the
future is a fixed point and where the
audience knows at least some of the
outcomes the drama at the scene to scene
level has to be engaging and it's this
kind of attention to detail that makes
better call Saul work as a drama
[Music]
this video is brought to you by
Squarespace start your free trial today
at squarespace.com / Thomas flight and
use code Thomas flight to get 10% off
your first purchase I've been a
Squarespace customer for years and I've
never looked back
recently I redesigned some of the
branding for my channel and updating the
look and feel of Thomas flight comm was
incredibly easy check the site out by
the way I've added a blog and a
newsletter where I post all my videos
and some other occasional content
Squarespace makes designing and running
a website a stress-free experience
they're beautiful templates give you an
amazing starting point for a design but
even if you want to get a little nerdy
with the CSS like I did you can it's
really simple and beautiful on the
surface and very powerful underneath
with Squarespace gone are the days of
installing plugins updates and patches
so start your free trial today at
squarespace.com slash thomas plate and
use code thomas flight to get 10% off
your first purchase thank you so much
for watching a huge thank you especially
to my patreon supporters to celebrate
50,000 subscribers had some Thomas
flight bird stickers made get one when
you become a patron at patreon.com slash
Thomas flight